[Music]
welcome
last year the conference huh had fun so
far
excellent awesome so again thanks for
taking the time to come over to this
session fruitball Bogle I'm part of the
Apogee product team and I'm super
excited to be joined on the stage here
with go pick up a tale from Global
Payments she will join us a little later
in the session and today we are going to
talk about how do you really accelerate
application development with cloud
services this is actually a topic which
has become very important as customers
are migrating to the cloud and
transition to the cloud and using more
and more services so we will walk it
through some some few things the first
housekeeping thing out here real quick
is this year at next we have Dory which
is an add the view internally for
questions and answers so inside of your
Google next app you'll see a Dory Q&A
link peace feel free to ask any
questions out there there are also two
microphones towards the end of the
session will be opening them up for Q&A
so we'll take live questions and also
will read questions from the Dory as
well okay with that so let's talk a
little bit about api's and digital
transformation you may have heard
throughout the conference around how
companies are trying to transform
digitally so what does that really mean
what it really means
at the end of the day is that they are
leveraging api's as the front and center
mechanism of exposing their capabilities
to a variety of different stakeholders
these stakeholders could obviously be
employees who are using some kind of
productivity applications it could be
your end consumers who are using your
services to get some benefit or it could
also be a big partner ecosystem who are
really deriving extended value from
these products so these products in the
new day and age are nothing but api's
and so if you look at this picture real
quick it talks about your core systems
such as a core enterprise digital assets
are the ones which have now moved away
from a system level or an integration
level detail to being an API those
deliver the connected experiences that
are very important this day and age so
why are we talking about this today well
what we are also seeing is as more and
more enterprises are becoming API first
they have began to move to the cloud and
are also leveraging a variety of
different kind of cloud services so
cloud services are great they give you
the ability to be able to use some
capability right away
at the same time they do require a
specific mechanism to interact with them
so on one hand the do offer you the
ill-at-ease to be able to innovate
faster but you also need to be able to
use them in a more efficient way so
let's quickly break down the anatomy of
how you access a cloud service now I'm
going to use an example for a Google
cloud service in general but this could
very well and equally apply to pretty
much any other cloud service so if you
think about a very typical access
pattern for any cloud service or even
your own service for that matter of fact
it involves a few key steps the very
first thing you do as an application
developer by the way how many
application developers or developers in
the house out here today Oh excellent
excellent so there'll be a lot more
goodness for you to hear about today so
the very first thing of the developer
that you do is figure out where are my
credentials to that service that I want
to access that's step one then you gotta
go manage how you store them second once
I have access to those credentials then
usually most likely you're going to hit
some kind of a token end point where you
will exchange that credential for an
access token that token is supposedly
going to be time-stamped and which me
if you have to manage the lifecycle of
is a token good do I need to refresh it
so on and so forth and once you do all
those three steps
finally you actually make a call to that
API that he desired to invoke which
means there's a lot of manual steps
there's a lot of redundancy that you
have to account for it is error-prone
what if you miss a step and more
importantly this is a common thing which
compliance teams and administrators do
not like they don't want developers
touching or messing with any credentials
that's what domain they want developers
to stay away from how many developers
out here have to work with credentials
okay just keep your hands up please for
a second how many out there never get
told by a compliance team about anything
at all is that other totally okay with
that if they are bring your hands down
okay so this is a very common problem
right
compliance is usually behind clean
separation of credentials provisioning
that's all compliance and offs using
certain capabilities
that's developers so then let's take a
look at how Apogee which is a full
lifecycle API management platform can
really help you develop these api's by
leveraging some of these newer cloud
services so what you see out here within
the within the picture out here is
Apogee the API platform also known as
Apogee edge it has full-featured
capability to have out-of-the-box
policies to support your security
requirements traffic management
transformations so on and so forth as
you start to go up in your API program
you want to ensure that you have enough
capabilities to be able to expose your
API so they can be consumed easily by
developers and then the analytics give
you that clean insight end to end not
only from an operational perspective but
also from metrics which cater to
different stakeholders such as our the
API is being used who's using them right
so on and so forth and now extensions is
a very useful capability that
we added it when GA October of last year
it was announced at Google cloud next in
London last year and today we are
pleased to announce some really cool
extensions that we have made available
to our customers but because extensions
become part of the core platform you as
a developer who's leveraging the API
platform can leverage all the ill at
ease and connect to those cloud services
very quickly and more importantly become
more productive in composing your api's
those are leveraging some of those cloud
services so as I mentioned it's all
about acceleration and Apogee extensions
as we will see them today in a demo and
gives you all the capabilities to be
able to leverage those cloud services so
what are extensions we look at them in
three different ways so first off
extensions provide a well vetted
framework which gives the ability for
our customers to be able to take a
policy based approach in accessing those
cloud services so what that means is of
course every cloud service is going to
have an API endpoint but what we are
talking about here is giving you as
developers access to those services
using policy based controls number two
we give you all the capabilities so you
can reuse those extensions very rapidly
and avoid the error-prone the redundancy
issue that we spoke about and last but
not the least this is our gateway into
providing all the new innovations so as
an example as customers adopt AI and ml
in their ap is this these extensions
give you the ability to be able to tap
into some of those services very very
quickly so today I am very pleased to
announce extensions general availability
of these five extensions which take our
catalog to a much higher number so cloud
authentication cloud functions which
give the ability to access protected
cloud functions cloud machine learning
engine bigquery and then we have really
bombed up
support for data loss prevention
extension which was released last year
but now we've added support for
templates if you have been around in the
conference we did demo some of these
extensions during one other session as
well so this brings the total number of
extensions to 16 and we haven't just
stopped at building extension only for
Google cloud services if you've been
attentive you've heard a lot of focus on
hybrid and multi cloud so today we'll
actually showcase to you and we did in
another session before as well that we
have gone and built extensions to other
cloud services as well so our customers
can leverage the API platform no matter
of where your workloads are on which
cloud provider you're able to seamlessly
access those services as well ok with
that if we can switch to the demo please
awesome son this in this demonstration
I'm going to walk it through the daily
life of a API developer so this would be
the persona or the role who are using
the apogee API platform for building of
these api's and we'll walk you through
how to leverage extensions and use these
cloud services to deliver to the api's
so I'm logged into Apogee edge out here
and this is the interface that I see
when we when I get in so I'm logged in
out here as an API developer right in
this case I'm going to be jumping back
and forth between the API developer
persona and the API administrator
persona as well so first off I have a
requirement to now go build an API and
get some employee data that data happens
to be sitting in bigquery traditionally
if I go into Apogee I can whip up an API
proxy an API proxy is nothing but a very
simple construct it gives you the
ability to be able to compose lot of
interactions with many services you can
use a lot of different policies out of
the box so I could very easily let's say
as an example go into one of these api's
I'll just look this one up as an example
and
the demo gods are with us today yes
there should be so within this API proxy
you can add a bunch of different kinds
of policies right so I can use traffic
management policies security mediation
policies and I can also use an extension
capabilities as well so it's a very
extensible platform so using a
combination of many of these policies I
can access pretty much any cloud service
or any other service that's out there
right
but that's something which we've been
doing for a long time so let's now focus
our attention on how does extensions
come in and really help that cause
so with that I'll actually first start
with looking at bigquery cause I'm going
to show you how you're going to use the
bigquery extension to get data in and
out of bigquery through Apogee edge so
in this case I switched over to bigquery
and I have a data set called human
resources and a pretty obvious table
call employees in this case let me run a
quick query in bigquery and once I get
the results out here assuming you guys
can see this I have about seven
different entries in there okay let me
see if I can mess with the resolution a
little bit okay a little bit better
right so this is actual data sitting in
there so now let's go over and see how
we can enable that experience with an
Apogee so the first thing you do now is
you go into this area where we call
extensions so the first step is go into
extensions and go add an extension as
you can see we have extensions to a lot
of the services that I just spoke about
you can click on any of these in this
case you typically go and click on
bigquery you give it a name and a
description so again this is the
administrator going and configuring this
extension once you do that and for the
purpose of this demo I'm going to use an
extension that I've query recently is
called BQ or bigquery employees
within this extension you typically go
in and you enter a few different
prerequisites so your GCP project ID the
same GCP project that I was just on and
the service account or the credentials
to call bigquery
so I've already deployed an instance of
the extension here and you can see this
is up and running and ready for us to
use so in this case having it as an
administrator I come in and I simply
configure the extension I deal with all
the credentials and this is ready to go
so now let's switch over to the API
developer persona I'm out here building
an API proxy and I already built one
color employees in this case instead of
me having to now deal with a bunch of
other things I am going to use the
extension collared policy so I'll go out
here and say extension call-out I will
select the extension that are just
deployed the BQE employees and now this
will present me a list of operations
which is already available so no longer
I have to worry about go and reference
the API documentation I have all the
methods that I need out here I can
select one of them and add the extension
call out policy it's already added out
here in this case we'll start with the
first use case which is trying to insert
a new record into bigquery okay so in
this case I'm going to call this flow
with an Apogee edge and as you can see
it is trying to put something that I
sent in in the request into that table
in bigquery so I'll use the trace tool
real quick I'll jump on to a revision
revision 2 and I'm going to postman
which is a tool that we commonly use to
test off so let's click on the insert
employee function so there
case I have a simple JSON payload this
is what I'm trying to insert into
bigquery
so let's hit send out here I'm going to
do that behind the scenes is making a
call to the apogee edge api proxy which
now leverages the extension you can see
it came back with a 200 ok so far so
good
so if I go into the trace tool I can see
that it did the right level of security
checks which is what he would expect to
do an Apogee and then it made a call out
to bigquery and actually tried to push
this data into a bigquery table so
actually let's go and query that so you
should have an idea of nine nine nine so
I go out here run another query and if
this has truly worked we should see the
last entry out there as you can out here
okay so again let's recap what we did
very quickly we used an extension which
was configured by the administrator and
the API developer simply lever that
policy and made a call to add data into
the query so then let's go over and run
the same thing for yet another use case
so in this case what I want to do is I
also want to run a list method which
also happens to be on the same API proxy
in this case I'm reusing the same
extension but in this case I'm calling
the list all rows method so if I run
this out here and I hit Send you can see
that if this was to work it's fetching
all the data from bigquery right again
I'm leveraging these cloud services but
I'm able to compose my API in a much
more quicker way all right now let's see
if you can use some other capabilities
within the extension so in this case
what I'm going to do is I will switch
over to the develop tab right here and I
will bump this to revision 3 which now
puts a limit clause so in this case
let's make sure I go and deploy this to
test I'll just create a new revision
other API proxy where I'm trying to
utilize another feature so in this case
in the list employees extension call-out
you can see I've used a limit clause out
here okay so this means it should now
limit the data coming back from bigquery
and I can control that from within the
extension so when I go and call this it
should only return me one item back okay
so far so good so now well I see a lot
of PII information is coming out but may
be employed error is sensitive and I
don't really want to mess with it I want
to ensure if a developer forgets about
this how do I put in the right controls
so this data doesn't go away
or doesn't escape the perimeter of the
enterprise boundary so turns out Google
Cloud actually has if first does
extension for that which is known as the
data loss prevention extension okay so
I'm going to show you an example of this
again it's pretty simple I'm switching
over to this console here which shows
you the the template support in this
case you can see that here is the
template from DLP data loss prevention
API has support for templates in this
case I'm going to use a specific
template which will show you how data
can be masked coming out of set in order
to do that I'm going to switch back out
here and I will turn to revision 4 which
has that policy already configured and I
will deploy that while that is deploying
I will showcase another important
concert with an Apogee now this is
something which you know fosters we use
shared flows is a set of reusable policy
that I can use and enforce across all
different api's so within this shared
flow which is something that you can
call from an API proxy I have a few
different things and the first thing is
you may have guessed it uses the DLP
template it uses the DLP extension and
tries to call that same template that we
just reviewed very briefly it will go
and apply that onto your payload okay so
within the API proxy going back to it
for a second
like lickin employees you can see in
revision for I'm making a call to the
shear flow using a flow color policy and
the shade flow has the data loss
prevention extension configured Solaire
now let's take it for a real quick spin
and now if I was to just run this it
should hopefully mask the data coming
out of bigquery so once this returns
what's really happening out here is I've
just simply taken this API proxy and
just added another extension to it
called data loss prevention where it
goes you gets data from bigquery Fusco
still using that extension and then
takes their information apply gels
prevention and then masks the data
coming out of it right
so hopefully that gave you a taste of
you know what the extensions are I
really quickly want to showcase some of
the other extensions that we've also
built other than the Google cloud
services you can see we have extensions
to support different cloud providers
they are generally available and out
there for you folks should try it out so
with that if we can switch back to the
presentation and at this point in time I
would like to invite over go pick up a
tail from Global Payments
Thank You Britta how are we doing guys
Thursday last day after lunch we are all
set all right okay guys and prepare by
the way cool new announcements for the
extensions specifically the DLP one we
might look into using that pretty soon
right so guys I'm gonna pick up a till I
lead enterprise integration steam at
Global Payments here with me I have the
Global Payments team say hi guys right
so what do we do so my team is
responsible for identifying the common
shared services needs across the
enterprise we build design deploy
support the common shared services
across the enterprise enterprise
integrations is an extension of
enterprise architecture responsibilities
and with me I have and Ally's gonna
shoot me we have a leaf of oz who is a
senior vice president and chief
Enterprise Architect at Global Payments
giant right Global Payments we are
today's innovators of tomorrow's
payments and technology solutions who
cool sentence I got it from my PR guys
but so we are a leading worldwide
provider for payment technology software
solutions driving innovative services to
our customers globally our technology
services and employees and enables us to
deliver broad range of solutions for
payment services so that our customer
can focus on their businesses
efficiently and basically market and use
the products across various distributed
payment channels how many of you we have
like FinTech or financial services
audience here just raise your hand
FinTech Wow PCI we all love it we have
Stacey or compliance lead here with us
okay
some facts and figures for Global
Payments
this basically shows the size of our
company we we do have over 2.5 million
businesses we support approximately
200,000 new customers or merchants here
140 payment methods 2.5 k global sales
personnel 3.5 billion in net revenues
11,000 employees 32 countries pretty
spread out globally 17 million
transactions per year of course customer
support 24/7 30 different languages so
that's this Global Payments testable
sighs so I want to talk about how a
Global Payments leverage Apogee gateway
today one of the biggest project if you
will we have is unified commerce
platform we launched it a couple of
weeks ago what is unified commerce
platform so the unified commerce
platform we plan to deliver the set of
api's which our customers or merchants
developers can integrate with easy
seamless easy to use integration simple
hiding the complexity of the Mac and
services at the gateway we receive a
transaction at the gateway we mediate it
and transfer it to the appropriate
back-end processors back-end services
and there you go so these api's we also
leverage a pages developer portal so our
customer developers internal and
external can go to the developer portal
take a look at this API test basically
or encode touch the API make the test
execution course which comes to our
integration environments and basically
run the test from the portal and there
you go we have we have developers now
who can use this and code to this api's
from the portal itself
our our plan is to have a full
self-service customer base or developer
base maybe we want to eliminate any sort
of hand-holding in very near future so
yeah it says up on the slides one
integration and a blink payments
worldwide across any channel or device
home speech a switch to this one so this
is obviously very high-level
architecture of unified commerce
platform we we do have various sets of
api's on the gateway transactions from
the FinTech industrial or the
transaction or authorization api's
disputes reporting data services data
api is providing for the real-time data
needs of the customers we do have
various channels or integrations where
they can basically call the api's which
connects the Gateway we have POS devices
many methods tabloids I pairs wherever
the different payment accepting channels
web browser for e-commerce transactions
the idea were here is simple we have
REST API is exposed on the Gateway very
easy covering the industry standard for
transactions disputes reporting etcetera
customers go to it transaction comes to
the gateway we mediate the transaction
into the complex internal services at
the gateway route the transactions to
the Global Payments back-end processors
mekin processors go connects to the card
brands card brands the regular business
response comes back and that transaction
is either authorized or declined so a PG
gateway basically gives us a very
powerful abstraction layer to hide all
the different complexities we have with
our processors those are complex those
are huge api's like I said it mediates
the complexity for us obviously we have
a whole suite of security layer on top
of the Gateway we leverage a whole bunch
of security policies for the Gateway
or off the Gateway so how does this
journey begin
Global Payments did head API gateways we
began our journey with Apogee late
December 2017 a year in it we purchased
the licenses for us Eun ap giving us the
global presence of the API gateway so
that we can basically accept the
transactions from all around the world
giving a speed and reliability in secure
and compliant manner fifty-five thousand
cause in production weekly is growing
this is remember we are one year in we
had the development QA certification
production we have a bunch of APs
already running in production and the
volume is growing as we speak we had
100% uptime since we launched no
downtime and again increasing adoption
across the world meaning with this geo
capability or global presence of the
Gateway we now can accept transactions
from all the corner for all from all the
corners of the world
so today the focus would be as a focus
is on extension and how we can assert
the development with we had Global
Payments do use the state travel logging
extension by logging why we started with
logging PCI requirements we have to log
every transaction that is hitting the
gateway specifically now as we are
launching transaction API steer API is
all of those and moving our internal API
is on the gateway as well every
transaction that hit the gateway should
be logged it is in our security and
architecture practice practice in Global
Payments audit requirements we do those
from the FinTech industries be run
through PCI compliance audit we have to
show the evidences of the logs how are
we collecting the logs these logs are
then fed into
GCP stackdriver where we have configured
alerting and monitoring of the logs you
can navigate to the issue faster
all of these logs are getting fed into
stackdriver we are an alert area
monitoring this logs we can navigate
through the through the logs with
different search parameters in the log
entry and get to this issue faster in
production environment consistent log
very important I'm going to touch on
that real soon
every transaction that hits the gateway
is logged in a consistent fashion who
where what why how this this is the
consistent format now across every API
we have traceability of course right we
have a full traceability by capturing
these parameters of who wore who where
what and how so this is this is how we
started with we started with logging we
had to log we had to log every
transaction coming the gateway so this
is how our Appaji flow looked without a
PG extensions you create the kvms assign
the project ID log ID use the variables
generate GCP tokens use the private key
cash it and connect to the GCP project
invoke the stackdriver service log it
asynchronously behind-the-scenes and
this if it hits they go and this is how
it is after applying the extensions to
steps you form the log message do an
extension call out to the stackdriver
extension that we have configured by our
or get means that's it
now the way we use this extension is
this extent this extension is created in
a shared flow and is implemented at a
flow hook level that means that any new
proxy I'm putting on the Gateway I do
not have to worry whether it is logging
or not logging because as you know
if it is in a flow hook that is going to
be executed I said so now any proxy
whether the developer remembers to add
log and extensions use extensions
regardless every transaction is now
getting logged this has helped us
tremendously in delivering the proxies
in a write compliant manner I'm logging
any proxy that I put on the Gateway in
fact a couple of minutes ago we just
added one proxy which was like a high
term priority for us in matter of hours
that's it our proxies out the in the dev
environment and very soon it will be it
will make its way to the higher
environments of QA certification Pradhan
so so that this we look we do look
forward to use more extensions as now we
have more announcements from Apogee dlp
is definitely a cool one PayPal we
definitely want to look at that so we
will be using or looking into using more
extensions at the platform benefits so
thanks yeah so thanks for sharing the
story go pika
I thought you walked us through how you
just very early on in your journey and
are just getting started and I'm pretty
sure you guys gonna hit some very high
volumes very soon and we are prepared to
ensure that you folks scale with your
platform by leveraging Apogee and thanks
for walking us through why logging has
become kind of this new money or
currency that we talk about because from
a compliance perspective this becomes
super important so just wanted to kind
of summarize we saw a lot of things
happening today we spoke about how do
you accelerate development of these
api's using cloud services we also
looked at some very routine ways of
doing that from the platform as you
showcased with your that comparison was
pretty awesome by the way
right you can still use the platform
it's completely extensible to do things
like log into stackdriver as an example
but then you also saw how extensions
were able to
very quickly compartmentalize them and
make it a 1 to show right mr. let's go
and configure it and the developers use
policy based controls so we were just
talking about this than we before we
came up as to some of the new extension
I think the DLP extension as you
mentioned especially the temperature
support is becoming very very important
for customers who have worried about
data security and the last piece that
you touched on I want to react oh go
pick I use a term called flow hook so
one thing which is super important to
understand is compliance is not an
option a developer may be very good at
heart and may remember to do all the
right things such as putting in all
those policies but what did they forget
ultimately the responsibility is with
the program to ensure that there is
compliance so flow hook is a mechanism
within the platform where you can use a
shape for the one that I called from
within my API proxy the same shared flow
can be configured at an environment
level so it automatically applies any
policies out there for all API traffic
going through that environment which
means from a compliance perspective you
can just add a shade flow with the
extension for DLP which is what we
demonstrated and you are using stack
driver log in such a way yeah as well
and the last thing to add to that is we
were also with this announcement now
provides support for a post client flow
so that means typically a logging is a
mechanism which is important but you
also don't want it to come in the way of
processing the API call so you can now
use the shared flow and that policy more
importantly in a post client flow which
means it can be done truly
asynchronously right so recapping that
first-class extensible self-service
approach to connect to cloud services
using these pre-built extensions very
rapidly connect to any service you've
already built 16 different extensions
that you saw 12 2 different Google cloud
services and some to other providers as
well and we definitely plan to continue
growing the catalog extensions the other
thing that we're working on today is the
same framework and the same development
methodology there
we as the Apogee team are using to build
these extensions we are planning on
opening up that framework to our own
customers so then you can take that
framework build your own extensions your
own services and reuse them within the
enterprise just like you can from the
pre-built extensions
okay awesome thanks everybody for coming
all right enjoy the rest of your day
[Applause]
[Music]